hey guys welcome to our brand new set of
the lobby that's our weekly show that's
on tuesdays at two p.m. but today is
February 20 seconds i'm your host mary
and you are watching gamespot news this
new set has brand new lighting which
makes it look good but it's also got
brand new mic so it sounds good you know
what else looks really good new graphics
in killer instincts microsoft's free to
play fighting game killer instinct
should look better than ever when the
season 3 update is released in march
developer iron galaxy is announced that
it is overhaul the game's graphics
engine as a part of the studio's effort
to fully utilize the power of the xbox
one in a blog post iron galaxy said you
might have already noticed the improved
graphics as new character kim woo stage
which was shown off during the live
stream in january contained the
improvements art director chad green
further explained killer instincts
visual changes in upgrades he confirmed
among other things that iron galaxy is
applying a lighting technology to all
existing stages not just the new season
three arenas these changes come to
killer instinct win season 3 arrives in
March which is also the month that the
fighting game will be released for pc
iron galaxy didn't say if the new
graphics changes would also apply to the
computer version of killer instinct
season 3 not only introduces the
graphics the changes and adds new
characters kim woo rash from battletoads
halos arbiter but also numerous
character tweaks and rebalances for
existing fighters Escom 2's already had
a lot of sweet mods so a star wars mod
was only a matter of time and it fits
right into if you're gonna miss all
their shots you might as well be wearing
a stormtrooper helmet you remember the
mod that made the assault rifle look
like a corgi well more geniuses are
putting their minds to good use now
there's Star Wars helmets players can
make their soldiers look like
stormtroopers both classic and
first-order scout troopers Boba Fett
even republic commando clone trooper the
mod also adds face paints that will
cover the exposed neck area so your
soldiers look apart Star Wars fans can
utilize new voice packs that
add to the role playing players can make
their soldier sounds like the bounty
hunter Boba Fett sev from republic
commando and a Twi'lek woman but if
they're going to sound like a Twi'lek
i'm gonna need the mod to give them
those droopy skin antlers too and our
final story is that Dark Souls 3 it's
now available for pre-order and as
expected they're incentivizing you buy
right now and this is the back wall of
our studio and the best part about it
it's got the secret wall so we can go
back there and change ahead of Dark
Souls 3 s launch in April the game is
now available to pre-order digitally for
ps4 xbox one and pc bandai namco has
confirmed the bonuses you get if you buy
the anticipated role-playing game ahead
of time people who pre-order Dark Souls
3 4 ps4 will receive a digital copy of
the Dark Souls 3 soundtrack as well as a
fire fades dynamic theme the theme is
available right away but the soundtrack
won't be delivered until the same date
is the game April 12 Xbox one pre-orders
from the Xbox store come with a free
copy of the original Dark Souls playable
through the consoles backwards
compatibility functionality bandai namco
notes that your code for dark souls
should arrive by way of xbox message 7
to 10 days after you place your order on
PC pre-orders for dark souls 3 on steam
come with game soundtrack additionally
if you already own dark souls or dark
souls 2 on steam you save five bucks on
the third one if you're excited for dark
souls 3 me and editor Mike already are
seeing it tomorrow we're gonna tell you
all about it once we're allowed to and
that's all the news I have for you today
I'll see you guys again tomorrow
hey hey I think it's and then it stopped
hey yeah its top dance darling stop
hello